while the team's playing in super bowl
55
might not have been decided the halftime
performer has
that's right the weekend has nabbed the
coveted title of pepsi super bowl 55
halftime show performer
and we couldn't be more excited the
weekend confirmed the news on twitter
writing performing on the iconic stage
see you
february 7th 2021 the grammy-winning
musician will take the stage during
super bowl 55 on sunday february 7
2021 at raymond james stadium in tampa
bay florida
something he's been dreaming about for
quite some time
saying in a statement quote we all grow
up watching the world's biggest
acts playing the super bowl and one can
only dream of being in that position
i'm humbled honored and ecstatic to be
the center of that infamous stage this
year
now this will be the second year roc
nation has teamed up with pepsi and the
nfl to bring the best and brightest
performers to the stage
with rough nation founder jay-z saying
this year will be
no exception the weeknd has introduced a
sound
all his own his soulful uniqueness has
defined a new generation of greatness in
music
and artistry jay-z said in a statement
adding
this is an extraordinary moment in time
and the pepsi super bowl 55 halftime
show
is going to be an extraordinary
experience with an extraordinary
performer yeah no kidding and if you're
feeling more than a little patriotic
about this choice
you have good reason the last time a
canadian graced the stage
was in 2003 when shania twain was the
halftime performer
so what are your thoughts are you loving
this choice as much as i am
or would you have chosen someone else
sound off in the comments below